well Selma was a nice reprieve but now
we're back in the January we've come to
expect blackhat so blackouts a movie
directed by Michael Munoz like Michael
Mann it could be awesome could be not
but you said a couple of great movies
under his belt he's got he's got
collateral is like oh right and then
black hat this hackers hacking things to
make it bad things happen they're like
alright we need the best hacker ever we
need zero cool from hackers but he needs
to look like Chris Hemsworth to say man
this is 2015 we need our hackers looking
pretty so the get Chris Hemsworth out of
jail no like are you're the best of the
best you need to help us stop this guy
now we have black hat a Michael Mann
movie that you will most definitely
sleep for at least half of it I'll say
this is about black hat this movie is a
testament to movie stardom the concept
that a movie star can be in a movie and
make a movie better for the fact that
the movie stars in it that's this movie
because you like this movie for one of
two reasons one Michael Mann directed it
and you will just love everything he
does or to Chris Hemsworth's in it and
you want to like it because Chris
Hemsworth that's kind of where I was
like well I mean I like him swarthy he's
foreign
we all love Chris Hemsworth I want
to like this movie and it almost me
she's thinking your head you're like
maybe I didn't good to be nice to this
movie I can't oh my god that was weird
look just weird psychological thing
where's this guy this movie star can
make the movie kind of better without
making the movie better because in
reality Chris Hemsworth being in this
movie is as boring as everyone else in
this movie because everyone in this
movie is born no one stands out no one
does anything special everyone is just
boring Chris Hemsworth's character has a
friend in the movie kind of by that
there's this romance in the movie you
don't buy that for when this
romance happened in the movie I was like
I get it just love her the dudes been
rotting in the can for a couple years
this is the first hot chick he's seen in
a while before they crack the case and
take down the super bad hacker she has
to experience the full gravity of Thor's
on liftable hammer he will show her the
me on their really man for the first
hour this movie I was like this is
putting me to sleep then the second half
of the movie starts to focus up it from
nothing else you get a couple of Michael
Mann shootouts those are always awesome
when a Michael Mann shootout happens in
a movie you feel like you are in the
you doubt man the sound is great guns
are going off you're like oh god it's
happening and I'm in it I'm not saying
you need shootouts to make a good movie
or a good thriller you can have a
perfectly great cyber hacker thriller
without a shot fired I'm just saying
when it happens in a Michael Mann movie
you have to address it and the fact that
it was the best part of the movie yeah
all five minutes that happened in this
movie great I'm like Tony the Tiger I
don't know why Michael Mann shootouts
water I feel like I'm on this
movie more than I should be because it
does have a couple of moments in Mobilio
that was the old uh I didn't see that
coming that was effective that was
awesome if the movie could keep you
engaged long enough to have moments like
that affect you more that would be
better when those couple of gents aren't
happening in this movie you're like mmm
when you have the first half of this
movie putting you to sleep in the next
actor all right maybe it's okay it's
well it's kind of focusing out of the
bad guys are cliche too
you can't deny the fact this movie's a
mess being honest with you you're not
gonna remember asshat and t-minus one
day yep already forgot Chris Hemsworth
does have a quality to it that dude
reminds me of Patrick Swayze if they
ever make that Point Break remake
they've been talking about for years
they should cast Chris Hemsworth as
Bodie I think that'd be great
so asshat yeah I'm calling it as head I
don't care have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
hacker thriller of all time whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]